there's so much manipulation that
happens in school how do you prevent
your children who are in school from
being manipulated in in whatever
whatever way well I mean first of all
you have to make it comfortable to have
the tough conversations without judging
them because that's they'll never bring
it up to you again if you have an
environment where your kids cannot come
and talk to you openly about issues and
you snap at them that'll be the last
time they'll ever bring that issue up to
you again so you got to make sure that
happens in one time too if you break
your eyes trust like yeah I agree I I
agree with you so I think that's on the
parent I think if the parent doesn't
create and like we have a rule out the
house you tell me the truth you're not
getting control you're not getting Papa
you're not getting nothing you just
gotta tell the truth so hey did you do
that yeah I punch him in the face okay
cool all right sounds good let's talk
about it why'd you do that okay hey did
you really take that idea did you open
up such and such as gift and without
their permission yes this was an issue
that happened two nights ago great so
you got to create an environment where
they can feel you have a creative trust
with them that they can talk to you
about issues right because if you don't
have that they're gonna go through it
they're just not gonna talk to you
they're going to talk to somebody else
and I think it's a mistake a lot of
parents and leaders make with their kids
um but yeah that's what I would say yeah
well said yeah you're communicating at
home you're mitigating for whatever's
happening yeah we watch you know we we
watched a movie uh uh uh where you know
the topic of uh lgbtq came up and my son
was a little bit confused he's nine
years old we came home and we talked
about it right and we sat down and I
told them the history of what I told
them I said here's what happened with
this here's what happened with that
these are the roles that father figures
play if a father is not really involved
a family is not involved or God is not
involved or you don't have a certain set
of values and principles we could be
confused to do stupid things we all can
be guilty of that but you're living in
an environment that this is what you
know and here's what to read this and
look at the history of this and here's
what happened with AIDS and here's how
AIDS got started and this is how many
people had killed and this and just you
kind of go through the history of it and
then let them make a decision for
themselves and I think that a lot of
parents sort of abdicate that because it
then it gets into this murky territory
and people people operate under a lot of
fear so a lot of parents back away from
those conversations they don't know how
to have those conversations that's why
that's how they convinced us that they
should be teaching sex in school as
opposed to leaving the parents to have
the sex conversations with the kids and
then the parents say okay now I don't
have to have the sex conversations with
the kids and I really commend you for
for bringing that up
um
I talked to my boys about six at five
and six years old I talked to them about
it young oh absolutely oh yeah birds and
the bees because they start like playing
with themselves and shouldn't you have
to have a conversation pretty yeah and
eight Boomer parents that would dude my
parents didn't tell me a [ __ ] thing
about mine too mine too right yeah not a
single [ __ ] no I don't think that's
healthy by the way I don't think I I
think maybe they got away with it back
then I don't I don't think you can get
away with it today at all because as you
get exposed to someone I know my mother
had huge conversations with my older
sisters and then I sort of got the brunt
of them but sort of you know second hand
in a sense yeah you know you know what
she did say that made me think about I
want to kind of get your thoughts on
this with the whole thing with kids
where you're saying well you're what
what are the three cons and she like she
wasn't given really the cons what what I
would say
homeschooling today is different than
homeschooling 30 years ago here's why
30 years ago if you're homeschooled
you're sheltered from The Real World
okay 30 years ago but if you're
homeschooled today but your kid still
has access to this you can't be
sheltered if this kid has got 2.7
million followers on Tick Tock it's
mathematically impossible to be
sheltered because 2.7 million followers
on Tick Tock that means you're also
going through the videos and you're
seeing [ __ ] that you disagree with
because we know what Tick Tock is doing
so a form of Sheltering to me without
social media today
a full-on shelter to me if you raise
your kids would be if you said no phones
no TV no movies no Netflix no nothing
that's a full-on shelter but if kids do
have Unabomber shelter yeah but if kids
do have access to this I don't think
it's the homeschooling of 30 years ago
what are your thoughts so here this is a
phenomenon you can see this most easily
like on maybe dating apps that I think
people have gotten into this mindset
that having the most Choice over
everything is the ultimate Freedom that
uh let's say I want to pick like an
ideal dating partner okay uh no
Republicans nobody from a small town
nobody that doesn't like this TV show no
no like people will ax out so many
things and they don't realize that if
they just met that person in real life
and like spent some time like chatting
with them hang out with them you'd be
really surprised at the wide gamut of
people that you could associate with and
engage with and and even have like
fulfilling friendships or relationships
with one of the things that I like about
school his school is one of the last
places where you are forced to be
together with whole group of strangers
and you have to adapt and socialize in
that situation and outside of school
it's very rare that those types of
environments will exist anymore maybe
work depending on your work environment
yeah but even work isn't all the same
age sure yeah so that so that's one of
the reasons why I like school that like
you got a bunch of kids saying a bunch
of crazy [ __ ] some of them you know you
wouldn't expect your kid to get along
with some of them you'd hope you'd get
along with but it's one of those few
areas where you're forced to socialize
with a wide variety of different people
and I think that that's a pro to um to
Child Development and I think it's a con
for younger kids because you don't know
what your kid is being exposed to sure
at early ages so at a certain point I
think it's healthy for for uh maybe a
conversation to happen about human
sexuality
um but not at age five with a stranger
yeah potentially but I think also
there's age limits I would draw the
development of children right so it used
to be that we we used to really protect
children actually before we started
protecting children we didn't protect
children they got married at the age of
seven and that was like totally
copacetic and Society said that was okay
then we said hey you know kids really
aren't of the age of consent until
they're 18 and we should protect
children and now we're entering into a
whole era where no no it's all we're
going to put it back all on the table
and children are sexual beings from
birth I mean they did studies on on
infants with sexuality and it's crazy
what they're what they've gotten away
with and those are the people who
develop the sex ed curriculum in our
schools and so now it's like totally
cool to talk to kindergartners about
sexuality and and gender non-conforming
uh things and lgbtq but you want to hear
what he has to say yeah so
um first of all I fully believe that the
age limits to sexuality are way way
lower than a lot of parents think I
don't know again this goes to the age
thing I'll talk to some parents in like
30s or 40s that will say just dude I
remember this one but the most
outlandishly stupid [ __ ] like my 17 year
old um you know he's got another friend
and sometimes he goes over to their
house and I think they study or whatever
and sometimes it comes back at like 10
or 11 at night and it's like what do you
know what they're doing the whole time
it's like they're [ __ ] right they're
obviously [ __ ] but like people can't
even accomplish them yeah like yeah at
like 15 16 13 years old no not my child
no way and it's like like how old are
you you really forgot everything like no
shot you think they wait until they're
18 to be sexually active um or even what
you said um I'm happy you said that
because it's it sounds weird to talk
about it as parents but like your kids
get sexual they start playing with
themselves at [ __ ] six months old
when their boys will start reaching down
every time you change their diaper and
they try to grab their dick and [ __ ] um
and it's important to have those
conversations early I think parents put
it off way too long I've heard obviously
my first hand experience but I've heard
horror stories that of how many women
have their first periods without their
parents ever telling them that it's
coming that's like child abuse that's
[ __ ] insane to me that your daughter
your little girl can just start bleeding
in a classroom thinking she's [ __ ]
dying and their mom was like oh haha
you've had your first oh wow um yeah
that so I feel like parents are
sometimes kind of bad at gauging the age
limits because for some reason they put
the blinders on when it comes to their
own kid and like my angel would never do
that so it's like what did you do and
then just real quick I just want to hit
the tick tock thing I think that the
tick tock Sheltering is a little bit
different and I think we have to be
really careful about this social media
is very good at showing you what you
want to see and it feeds you that
information of what you want to see and
it gets you scrolling scrolling
scrolling
um classroom environments are a bit
different because you're going to be
confronted with people that you might
not necessarily like so I think that
they're even though it doesn't seem like
it I think that a child that spends all
day on Tick Tock connected to 50 million
people can actually end up way more
shelter than a child in a classroom with
15 other people just because on Tick
Tock you're seeing a custom tailored
machine learning fed algorithm that is
giving you exactly what we see the
entire time whereas in school there
might be like a bunch of weird kids that
you do or don't get along with so yeah
his point was simply that they're less
sheltered because of social media today
than they were 15 years ago not that
they're less shelters it's just you're
seeing a fultonite ideas today
I just have two questions for the panel
just so I can get some clear directive
yeah not the one with the kids at what
age do you guys think it is appropriate
we got three minutes to have that sex
conversation with your kids just very
clear
you talked you said five six years old
you said I was five six years old yeah
at what age you know what sex birds and
the bees five six years okay all right
and then here's my question for you just
to kind of give you a binary choice
depending on the child sure it entirely
depends on the child some children don't
want to have that conversation okay we
won't have that conversation if there's
curiosity then you feed the Curiosity
and you I think I should force one out
of the conference because you're not
going to talk to them about it if you're
not going to talk about it they're
[ __ ] friends at school are going to
talk to them to the punch
binary choice for you would you think
it's more important to home teach your
kids
K through six
and then send them to school you know
middle school and high school or is it
more important for them to go to like a
public school
K through six and then homeschooled them
for middle and high school do you
understand the question I'm saying I do
what's more important if you can only
pick one I think K through six to do
what to to keep them home keep them home
until they're 12 years old and then send
them out to the real world yeah versus
then release them to the Wild and then
bring them back exactly that makes sense
okay yeah just one because hopefully by
the age of 12 they they understand that
they don't need school yeah they don't
want them hanging out because you want
you want your children to learn how to
teach themselves once they learn how to
teach themselves they won't take crap
from people so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]